dangerous heat for millions of people in
the west cooling centers are open from
california to colorado
states where temperatures are expected
to be well above 100 degrees in some
places
again today on friday the intense heat
buckled the pavement
along parts of interstate 80 west of
sacramento death
valley could break a record today set to
potentially hit 130 degrees or higher
adding to the trouble in the west more
than 50 large
wildfires burning in at least 15 states
including a fire that's consumed more
than 38 thousand acres in south central
oregon
and is threatening 3 thousand homes
meteorologist jeff burdelli is tracking
it all
jeff it has been a very busy spring and
summer for you and out west for sure
good morning jeff
good morning everybody so for the second
time in two weeks we are talking about
not just a heat wave but a historic heat
wave we hit 130 yesterday in death
valley the
highest temperature ever reliably
measured on earth we could hit 131
or 132 during the day today
50 million people right now under heat
alerts in the west here's a look at a
list of some
all-time records that could be
challenged or broken today there's death
valley 131 reading
118 las vegas 117 degrees look at palm
springs 119 notice
that the core of the heat is not in the
pacific northwest it's down in the
southwest
and across california when you wake up
in the morning palm springs you are
92 so there's no relief 104 in the
morning
in death valley and look at redding
california tomorrow afternoon
a temperature of 117 degrees here is
some of the recent
heat headlines it's been the hottest
june on record
for the united states also unfortunately
the driest on record once again
across the west coast and a study came
out on that pacific northwest heat wave
they say it was a one in 150 000
year event before climate change
and as we head towards 2040 or 2050 it
could be a once in
five year event that's how quickly
things are changing
but i'll remind you that we are the
captains of this ship
we control our destiny and how hot we
get with our policies and our actions
but first you have to accept right jeff
exactly all right well thank you so much